Albert Brewer joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show from the mmq be happy
New Year to you Albert Happy New Year
rich right back at you okay so let's
start with the coaching vacancies right
now the one that really surprised me
today was Adam GaSe why did the Dolphins
fire him Albert what happened there I
think it was anything else
Steve Blass wasn't happy with the
climate this building and you know
really I think this is about unifying
football operations and you know I got a
week ago it seemed as if Mike Tannenbaum
would be the one that was out then I
know that ownership there heard some
chatter that that Adam GaSe you know
could wind up garnering interest from
other teams and there was the question
are you gonna take the 53 away from Adam
GaSe khatola 33 man roster away from him
if you do that what Adam GaSe tried to
escape and it was just there were so
many moving parts there rich so if
you're gonna get rid of Mike or reassign
Mike and then you're looking at bringing
out him back and you get the sense of if
he doesn't want to be there and you have
this feeling that things might be a
little unhealthy on the football side of
your building to begin with what do you
do and I think what Steven Ross decided
to do here was to take the one guy it's
been a unifying force in that building
in that side of the building in the
general manager Chris career and put him
in charge and so I think it really just
boiled down kinda you know an owner
who's seen stripe and football
operations before seeing it start to
crop up again and trying to nip it in
the bud as quickly as he could okay so
who which which team is yet to fire a
coach do you think or do you think the
eight vacancies that we have now in the
Browns Jets Broncos Bengals Dolphins
Packers Cardinals and Bucks are gonna be
the only ones do you think right now
keeping an eye on of course you know
there's like some low-level buzz on the
Vikings I think Mike Zimmer stays there
Carolina you know Ron Rivera stays there
you know I the jaguars of course there's
been some talks there could be some
change at different levels of the
organization now but the guys in charge
are going to stick around there
I really still think
the one name to watch the one need to
continue to watch is John Harbaugh there
were lots of teams that have been sort
of doing their research over the last
couple of months that we're gearing up
for a run at John Harbaugh and I just
look at the landscape and some of the
names out there and I don't think it's
either gonna quit on the idea of going
after John Harbaugh whenever the Ravens
are out of the playoff one and so I mean
that what I throws that possible however
everything yeah here's the thing rich
okay like what you want to watch here is
does he sign an extension or does he not
sign an extension because things haven't
been perfect for John there the last
couple of years and so you know does he
want more control how does he think
wants things set up under under the new
general manager Eric Acosta hi this is
going to be a different organization
than it was under not to use them for
all those years and so you know I think
that there are some things that need to
get right there before John decides you
know I'm gonna go forward with this and
sign an extension and one thing that
obviously exacerbates all this is the
fact that he knows you'd have options in
other places and so I'm not saying
anything's gonna happen i I think
ownership well beyond horrible right you
know and it once how about back of the
coach what I would tell you is that you
know John Harbaugh does have a hammer
here and that there's only one year left
on his contract and he knows there's
interest out there and so what I would I
will tell you is that there are teams
that are closely monitoring what's going
on and teams like the Jets like the
Dolphins like the Buccaneers like the
Broncos that you know had planned to
make a run or take a hard look at
bringing John Harbaugh in is their next
HECO - I don't think it's quite willing
are quite ready to give up on the idea
of the year well I mean we'd have to be
talking multiple first right we'd have
to be talking like a Gruden to Tampa Bay
situation and you know III think you got
to give Steve bisciotti some credit here
- and in handling a story that he's
handled over the last month because my
understanding is sort of a look at this
and I you know I think about six weeks
seven weeks ago we were driving towards
a you know potential mutual parting of
ways and I think Steve bisciotti
you know gotta you know definitely got
when - the fact there were lots of teams
that were sort of circling
around his head coach and I think he
looked out there at the landscape and
what's out there you know as far as head
coaching candidates this is we'll wait a
second like this isn't a great market
for head coaches to begin with and I'm
gonna let my guy go and be the number
one candidate out there that doesn't
make any sense at all you know and so I
think Steve bisciotti deserves some
credit for kind of bringing this thing
back in and I mean look Jenna has done a
great job over the last two months or a
year you know reconfiguring the office
around Lamar Jackson and putting them in
a position to make a playoff run and so
I need the question here is really going
to be whether or not you know that the
Ravens can get you on Harbaugh an
extension whenever the season is over
and if they can't get him signed to
extension I would expect that there
would be some teams you know and a lot
of this depends of timing of course the
Ravens are out this weekend and that's
different than the Ravens being out for
weeks from now of course but you know if
the timing lines up you know I could
certainly see if John decides to box if
the idea is kind of an extension there
where you're gonna have some other
suitors lining up with your optics
saying what's gonna take for us to get
John Harbaugh out of all Albury of the
mmq be here on the Rich Eisen show
what's going on in Pittsburgh I'm
hearing about a lot of dysfunction in
that locker room that we don't know
about that's typical of Mike Tomlin to
keep it in-house and try and put it
together but but I'm hearing he's having
more and more difficulty trying to
squeeze toothpaste back in the tube over
there Albert what are you hearing
complicated they've always had these
sorts of psychosis right like the paint
from Chuck Noll Dotel tower those might
come when they've always had guys who
are sort of the balance of commander
types who can handle big personalities
and can manage groups of people and
that's always allowed them to cast a
very wide net talent standpoint and so
they've been able to keep a lot of
things in-house over the course the last
two years what big personalities like
Le'Veon Bell like Antonio brass allows
them to take risks on guys like
martavius Bryant you know Ben
Roethlisberger hasn't always been the
easiest guy to deal with and so the one
thing that that's interesting about
their situation is that I don't know
that you can take that roster and
transfer it onto another head coach and
expect the same sort of results that my
column of god they really built that
roster for my Tom
where he is uniquely qualified I think
to manage the big personalities in that
building and so I certainly could see
some staff changes coming I wouldn't be
totally shocked if Keith Butler winds up
retiring or there some sort of parting
there I think there are gonna be some
changes and I think there will be a
little bit of a shaking up of the way
things are being done there I don't
anticipate there being any wholesale
changes at the top level of the
organization just because they're set up
in such a unique way where yeah again I
think you know my comments uniquely
qualified to leave okay so now obviously
word is on the street that the browns
are interviewing Mike McCarthy there was
also a report out of the state of
Arizona that it's actually a done deal
where do things stand on on the coaching
searches that have been open the longest
on Green Bay and and Cleveland as best
you could tell right here the day after
this is Robert yeah I Cleveland's wide
open I don't say Cleveland's gonna look
at offensive coaches
I think gays will be in play there don't
look at defensive coaches don't look at
guys who you aren't coordinators right
now I think Campbell I also expect them
to look in the college ranks like I you
know I've heard for two months now the
Matt Campbell at Iowa State is
somebody's they're pretty hot on and so
you know the Browns have planned all
along to have a wide open process and
that will include
you know the two guys in house Greg
Williams and then Freddie kitchens and
that's the way I'd expect them to go
forward I
hacker's the Packers are pretty far
along they've already brought in some
guys and interviewed them and you know
they've sort of set it up so they're
going to be able to move fairly quickly
josh mcdaniels is high on their list
because you know there's the recognition
in that building there aren't that many
people on the planet capable coaching
someone like Aaron Rodgers and Josh
obviously has you know the unique
experience of having coached Tom Brady
which would kind of put him in that
category there's Pat Fitzgerald at
Northwestern who has the connection of
Mark Murphy Mark Murphy actually
elevated into the head coach and we're
all at or clustered so I think the
Packers are a little further along the
Browns are committed to doing a
wide-open search and looking under every
Rock and you know I think that that John
Dorsey wants to think outside the box
with his high
the Packers I think are a little bit
more streamlined and a little further
down the road and I could see them
making a higher a little bit quicker and
then you mentioned Mike McCarthy I think
McCarthy is the one right now the right
people are looking at I think I put
Arizona in this category I put Tampa in
this category on the New York Jets
potentially where you know teams are
starting to look at Mike McCarthy and
say is this Andy Reid you know nobody
was looking at Andy Reid is this you
know offensive innovator six years ago
when the Eagles fired him but he took
the opportunity to sort of reinvent
himself and infuse new ideas into what
he was doing and it's been incredible
for six years in Kansas City a lot of
people look at Andy Reid it might cost
you the same way as a guy who's capable
and smart enough to reinvent himself and
so you know like someone like Arizona
who struck out on Andy Reid six years
ago is going to look at it Tampa I think
he's looking for a name higher I
mentioned John Harbaugh there I think
Mike McCarthy's the mix in Tampa as well
you know and the Jets sort of see him as
somebody who could be a stabilizing
force so you mentioned McCarthy I think
he's names gonna be out there he's gonna
play about it well when the Jets look at
case I mean case knows how to beat
newing I'm clearly in his own building
and he knows a division why wouldn't the
Jets try and see alright let's let's
look case up with Sam Donald right now I
think I think I think case will be in
play in both New York and Cleveland and
I think that's very much about you know
the young quarterbacks and about some of
the connections and those two buildings
to to Adam GaSe you know look I mean
what Jimmy has when it goes back to the
relationship with Peyton Manning in
Manning having the early tip with Adam
GaSe I mean gate gates actually came on
to have Long's radar in 2014 when he
hired Mike pet gates actually declined
an interview request their then
interview included on their 2016 so
they've gone down the throat a couple of
times I could certainly see that
happening and I did the Jets are in play
too I do know that the Jets last week
you know and when all this was going on
the tunnel the Miami building the Jets
had done some research on Adam GaSe so I
wouldn't be surprised if they're
prepared to bring him in pretty quickly
okay Alvar pre here on the Rich Eisen
show you know I do remember time as I
see McDaniels name out there were the
handful of places yeah I do remember
time
when he left an NFL team in the lurch so
unprecedented ly Robert that the
prevailing wisdom was he would never get
a coaching interview again so I guess
nobody nobody nobody's concerned that
what happened with the Colts anymore
basically I would say that I think I
think if you talk to Chris towered about
it right like he was the one who was
most affected by this because he's the
one who had to restart the coaching
search at a very difficult time to do
that the beginning of February right
like I think if you if you talk to Chris
towered about it what he would tell you
is that there were some fit issues that
they just didn't address quickly enough
during that process and that everyone
wound up getting the best result and I
don't even think this is about power
rich I this is about structural stuff
like who hires the trainer's who hires
the strength coaches you know how is the
program set up and you know in some
organizations the organization's Chris
Tyler's been in the general manager does
that and in other organizations the head
coaches in charge of everything like
that that's you know obviously where
Josh has been and so there was a little
bit of a philosophical divide there that
for one reason or another and those who
had been talking for eight nine months
but the one reason or another that
didn't come up till the very end and
because of that you know you you know
you get to the end and Josh gets cold
feet you know the craft swooped in and
they say okay well what do you think
about this to stay because they really
wanted to have some sort of young talent
on their coaching staff
coming up and you know obviously you get
the result that you get but I think that
there are some teams that are sit down
with Chris out and talk to Chris Tyler
would get some reasonable answers and
probably already have got some
reasonable answers on why here all right
Albert ask the poll question of Albert
as we send him out the door Christopher
go for it all right Albert what's the
best job available Browns Broncos
Cardinals Jets Packers Cleveland I love
the Cleveland job because I think Baker
Mayfield a superstar I like a lot of the
young count on their team for miles
Garrett so Larry Okeechobee Joe Schobert
Denzel Ward Jabril Peppers Jarvis Landry
they got a lot of good like under 26 on
their roster they've got a ton of money
to spend and so for the first time in a
long time because that was a bad job in
a few of these recent cycles I think the
Cleveland Jobs the number-one job in the
market and I think that's going to be
reflected in the image that you see
they're gonna be pursuing that job
not great Albert I mean you're right
Mayfield's a star and at this point last
year nobody thought he was number one
overall pick nobody not a single human
being I know I don't even know if John
Dorsey did oh I'll tell you this it's
like last year at this point like I
remember putting him at the bottom of
the first round of a mock draft right
right around Christmas three years I put
him at like big twice 27th pick and
people thought I was crazy for that you
know so it's amazing how much that's
evolved and what will be fascinating to
is to see how this affects the way teams
look at quarterbacks going forward if
this could change the way the team's
evaluate quarterbacks they come out over
the next few years
Albert happy New Year to you and enjoy
the Rose Bowl I hope I enjoy it enjoyed
soak it in man so couldn't enjoy III
appreciate that you enjoy basketball
seasons really have something going
there take care of it we'll chat down
the line all right you got it that's
Albert prayer the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience